poi ho appena finito di vedere il re
leone il live action un po di
considerazioni
l'ho visto che in cui originale quindi
le critiche sul doppiaggio non le posso
condividere perché non l'ho visto
proprio quindi non so come abbiano
aspetto non me lo vedo invece col
doppiaggio scenette col doppiaggio farmi
vedere mentre intanto prepara il film
volevo comunicare di questa riflessione
anche ho fatto la prima è mufasa scusate
la metterò così vengono ameba mi
interessa ormai il previsto ogni angolo
del mio corpo tranne angoli che non
dovrebbe mostrare ma non serve youtube
sarebbe youporn io non lo trovate
diverse visse lio che rado il terremo di
felicità ho appena ricevuto il regalo
non un regalo di compleanno il regalo
l'unico regalo che il mio compleanno una
cosa meravigliosa hard a te l'ho io già
mi sento meno stressata solo a
spogliarlo nonna stan facendo sto
impazzendo il fratello prima cosa la
morte invasa rientra in una di quelle
scene di film così traumatiche che io
ogni volta penso che non succederà non
voglio che accada e invece poi accade
ogni volta ed è sempre una tragedia
spetta qui c'è pure dumbo faccia
dolcissima tombo mettiamo a caricare
così proprio per bloccare completamente
la nostra crescita amate gli occhi
dolcissimi non ce la faccio dicevo la
morte di mufasa assolutamente traumatica
e la mia cara amica neva leoni
la trovate su instagram attrice ma anche
secondo me donna super super super in
gamba e divertente mi ha fatto anche
ragionare che effettivamente timon e
pumbaa e la prima coppia arcobaleno che
adotta un bambino e lo fa crescere un
leone milioni di prima ora è ovvio che
timon e pumbaa non sono una vera coppia
arcobaleno ma sono comunque due uomini
suricato un facocero che insieme con la
loro amicizia diciamo riescono a far
crescere un giovane bambino peloso e
fanno diventare un essere migliore è
un'azione molto bello questo nome dovrò
anche mettere in moto prima che youtube
pensi che io stia utilizzando i
copyright e compagnia bella no non ne ho
voglia e l'amore avvolgerà quale quella
deve essere bellissima perché comunque
ogni elisa che cantano ciao sim e
richiama un momento glitter perché è
appena arrivato il corriere di amazon e
mi ha consegnato un altro regalo e di
fegato questo assolutamente consono al
mio rango una roba perfetta la adoro ci
andrò anche a fare la spesa per il mio
compleanno ovviamente succedere sta per
succedere combattimento terribile due
leoni che si prendono a pizze simba
abbozza sempre a stagione
questa è la voce di pumbaa dove le
conoscete
scusate cuba non parla come bomba e mal
non parla come di monna emessa di che il
problema sono marco mengoni elisa
scusate ci inchiniamo quelli prodotti
servitori e ci inchiniamo quali fedeli
servitori ragazzi in inglese le voci
sono molto simili all'originale perché
hanno fatto sta scelta che va marzo
ammazzo io ammazzo per questo la scelta
di timon e pumbaa bestia io ne ho già
capito cosa ancora si stanno innamorando
e il nostro io adesso no ragazzi ha sede
il loonie è un attimo kosir romantico
del drago
no
dopo
no no no no
ok no allora 2 pazzeschi effettivamente
il vero problema timon e pumbaa bocciati
vergogna vergogna i doppiatori vergogni
e doppiatori che hanno osato osato
mancare di rispetto a un kart wii
capolavoro della disney basito e
schifato questo qui è il mio commento
perché la scelta del doppiaggio perché
la scelta di non ricalcare le voci
inglesi ma di fare una cosa nuova
completamente arbitraria perché queste
iubris queste presunzione non v è
notevolmente le stime sera vado molto
fiera di questi due broker o bon ton
fammi schiera un po qui un po di resa
nato mi sto andando a fare la spesa per
il mio compleanno ho mantenuto la
promessa fatta a mette totti ma di
questa cosa ma soprattutto non sto
andando da sola ragazzi perché ho
ascoltato il vostro consiglio e mi sono
fatta un fedelissimo assistente
domestico che chiameremo tardi e servi
saluta così non dovrò più incollarmi le
bottiglie di di nove diventare maciste
interrompiamo secondo le trasmissioni e
preparativi al compleanno della linea
per ricordarvi che la setta dei libri
che il mio club del libro su instagram
questo mese leggera possiamo salvare il
mondo prima di cena giusto di jonathan
safran foer se volete unirvi alla 7
litri venite a cercarci su instagram è
un libro particolare ho letto il periodo
dell'albero della rancia e durante
questo breve isolamento e maggio invece
abbiamo questo qui è un approfondimento
molto interessante scritto suo nome da
una penna pazzesca specialmente per
questo tipo di narrativa che quella di
jonathan safran foer che ha scritto
anche se niente importa è invece tutta
volta una roba sull'alimentazione il
momento mi sto molto interessante perché
tutto quanto legato al clima e continua
a essere un problema che non ci poniamo
c'è il covip cia terrorizzati
giustamente il clima che ammazza più
persone non riesce ancora a
terrorizzarci ancora non riesco a capire
esattamente qual è la nostra analisi del
pericolo cos'è che fa scattare questo
comportamento è dannoso e pericoloso e
anche letale non lo so ci siamo usciti a
trasformarci in un paese che indossa la
mascherina senza imbarazzo vergogna cosa
che un tempo solo metà uno scatenato
rimane il captcha invece adesso è una
cosa di uso comune come che non
riusciamo a trasformare altri gesti e in
qualcosa di uso comune non so se sia un
qualcosa debba partire dall'alto
veramente per goderci imporre in qualche
modo degli atteggiamenti nello stile di
vita più sano non tanto per noi monte
del nostro pianeta che abitiamo nome so
collato insomma che voglia che ho fatto
bene di leggerlo comunque io continuerò
insomma tutti quanti gli adepti della
setta video un pochino dove mi porterà
questa lettura linea lavinia non è
arrivata il grande momento sono pronta a
preparare la mia torta di compleanno non
è preparata ora probabilmente da sola o
gb in diretta con questa visuale viene
meglio decisamente meglio e chi è qui un
marito ci sono gli altri ingredienti ho
dovuto separare per fare il secco e la
crea ma per il semplice fatto che sarà
rincoglionita vi sono venuto un grande
talento ai fornelli e quindi volevo
evitare mi sono già stato andrea
buongiorno a stelline del cielo e del
firmamento sono qui mi sto facendo un
piatto di pasta che era dei secoli che
non mi faceva un piatto di pasta
bugiardo ho iniziato questa giornata in
realtà con un quesito una domanda
scusate questa fase ii mista un attimo
lasciando interdetto aiutatemi a capirlo
meglio c'è stato detto che in questa
seconda fase potremo finalmente
incontrare naturalmente con ratio
intelligenza seguendo tutte le norme che
ci sono state dette che ormai abbiamo
fatto nostre in queste settimane i
nostri congiunti inizialmente era
solamente tu madre o tu no nel punto di
morte poi si è evoluta in anche la
ragazza se è un affetto stabile e oggi
leggevo una cosa che diceva in realtà
fino al sesto grado di parentela quindi
fondamentalmente tu potresti incontrare
tuo cugino di terzo grado su moglie
posso incontrare per levante gente che
magari non ho mai visto in vita mia e
non posso incontrare altre persone
quindi la domanda è perché io posso
andare a visitare il chihuahua della mia
pro prozia e non possa andare a
incontrare un amico che un affetto
stabile col quale praticamente all'asilo
non lo so ci sputavamo in bocca per
lavarci i denti e nei momenti di
difficoltà veramente ci siamo cagati
l'uno nel cupo e l'altro non l'ho capita
che è meglio secondo me la carenza di
zuccheri che mi sta infondendo
sicuramente sicuramente c'è la
spiegazione che leggerò qua sotto
oggi mi sono svegliato polemico così che
bello è che causa ragazzi qualora non si
fosse capito a breve è il compleanno di
lavinia e voglio farle un regalo ma mi è
venuto un dubbio perchè lo sanno
qualcosa con la pole dance
solo che poi ho detto già tutto quella c
al pala casa tutta l'attrezzatura per
poter fare pole perché no fa ormai da
anni e quindi mi son detto qualcos'altro
qualcosa che non sia pole dance volevo
pensarci chi scrive nessuno volevo
pensarci da solo ma poi mi sono detto
perché quando posso avere tante teste
che mi danno una mano che cosa potrei
regalare alla linea se l'avete seguite
se state vedendo in questo video avete
capito che tipo di persona è totalmente
squilibrata quindi cosa potrebbe
regalare una persona totalmente
squilibrata che non sia una camicia di
forza perché comunque sta arrivando
l'estate molto probabilmente
risolverebbero lasciarle quindi no co.ge
si recano che ti lega lo è in questo
periodo saprei cosa regalare un partner
verso nel delle donne da fuori ma no non
mi sembra il caso
voglio farlo uno di quei regali che lei
dice no che si commuova non voglio che
si commuova come mia nonna s'è commossa
con il photobook voglio che si commuove
che dica soldi che hai capito voglio
quel tipo di commozione con la
commozione superficiale giorno 55 di
quarantena domani al 4 maggio data che
sancirà la fine della fase 1
volevo dunque raccontarvi come ho
passato il mio tempo in questo nefasto
periodo via
[Musica]
all'inizio tutto sembrava facile
ero felice mi dedicavo alla lettura
lavoravo in smart work diretta volte le
false guarda alle storie belle durano
poco era un improvvisa meno degli aiuti
i capelli quel giorno qualcosa in me
cambio non era più lo stesso ero
diventato più scontroso più irascibile
[Musica]
martinelli non è vero dunque capì che
era arrivato il momento di cambiare aria
di conoscere qualcuno che mi amasse per
quello che ero solo che non potevo
uscire
fu lì che conobbi bobba lui sì che mi
capiva insieme ci divertivamo un sacco
eravamo fatti l'uno per l'altro ma che
stai a dì a gambe
[Musica]
passavamo tanto tempo insieme a ed ios
ma mia seconda vita ma presto qualcosa
andò storto
bob stava sempre fatto e non parlava mai
ma perché non parli mai decisi di
liberarmene in quel momento del bisogno
d'altro
pensai a lungo un piano mi serviva un
pretesto per poter uscire di casa e
l'idea mi pare no in testa mi comprai un
cane e lo chiamai pretesto presto mi
accorsi che pretesto era solo un peluche
dunque tornai a casa sconsolato e non so
per quale motivo decisi di lavarmi dopo
mesi il prossimo episodio
[Applauso]